in Kaliningrad the architecture looks
German the neighborhood some German
names and it's most famous resident was
Germany's most renowned philosopher
Immanuel Kant but this is not in Germany
this is Russia the city began its life
as canings Berg a fortress built by the
Teutonic Knights in the 13th century
over the next 700 years it changed hands
twice until 1946 when in the wake of
World War two canings Berg went back to
Russia and was renamed Kaliningrad
needless to say German heritage was not
widely celebrated in the post-war years
but after nearly 75 years of peace
enough time has passed for the people of
Kaliningrad to start embracing their
complex history nowadays football World
Cup and whole world are looking at
Kaliningrad it's a kind of our own
desire to know about ourselves about our
history that's why we do all this
restoration projects all around the city
and all around the region when most
people think of Kaliningrad they picture
it's beautiful beaches or it's quaint
fishing village but when you visit here
it's easy to see its multicultural
history although it's German past has
been mostly hidden in recent years
apparently took the FIFA World Cup to
help bring it out
[Music]